こんばんは
はじめしゃちょーです。
誰が Tシャツと同じ髪色やぁ💢
バカにしとんのか
皆さんは
儀式というもの
信じますでしょうか世の中にはいろんな儀式があります
中には
危険な霊を再びこの現世に降霊させるという危険な儀式もあります
僕は昔ひとりかくれんぼという危険な儀式をやろうとしたんですけど
一緒にやろうとしていた後輩が急に泣き出して急遽
中断になったという過去がございます。
それ以来儀式みたいなことはやめようと思ったんですけど、
まあ夏なんで
別にいいじゃね　　　　 wii（棒読）
みたいな感じでちょっと別のやつをやってみようかなと思っております
これは僕はあんまり聞いたことなかったんですけど謎のアカウントと名前がない謎の
ツイッターアカウントから寄せられた儀式でございます
読ませていただきます
絶対にやってはいけない恐怖の儀式太郎君と花子さんをやって
ほしいです少しひとりかくれんぼと似ているかもです
1、紙で人形を3体作る。うち2つを赤と青で塗る青が太郎くん
赤が花子さん
ひとつは自分の身代わりとして爪や髪の毛を貼る。
賑やかですね
宣言後自分の身代わりを好きな所に置く
こっわぁー　鳥肌がもうやばすぎ
おまけみたいになってるんですけど
最後に一文 　人形はお焚き上げをしてください、、、
と、きています
せっかくの夏休みなので
今回は
この怪しい儀式
ようへゐくん部屋でやらせていただきます
いや、今初めて聞きました（萎）
僕の部屋めっちゃ人がいるんですよ
人が居すぎてちょっと降霊術がうまくいかなそうだったんで
ようへゐくんの部屋でやっぱここは霊感ない組なんで
全くないんですよー
ワッ　ネェー
ワァッ　　ウェェェイ（怯）
要するに２０分間　なんかバレなければいい
やってー　　ゆぅくぅ⤴
順番にやっていきましょう
はい。というわけで紙で人形を３体作りました。
これはそれぞれ太郎くん、花子さん
僕の身代わりという感じで3体準備していきます
また母ちゃんに怒られるんだろうなぁ
ということで太郎君と花子さん塗っていきました
自分の身代わりとして僕の爪や髪の毛を貼ります　　　うわぁ
これふざけんなよ　　こんだけブリーチしたのに抜けねえよ髪の毛よ
はい
というわけで
花子さんを部屋の隅に置き
太郎君を別の部屋に離して置きます。
その時
太郎君の体の一部を花子さんのそばに置いておく
太郎君の左足切らせていただきます。
それぞれ持ち場所に置いていきましょう
花子さんと太郎君のちぎった部分を部屋の
隅っこに置きます
太郎君を別の部屋に離しておくと　はい
トイレに置きます。
置きまーす
見て
ただならぬ何かを感じてる。
ほんとに怖い
いきます花子さんの大好きな
太郎君は
僕が殺しました
憎いですか？
今から20分間
僕は部屋のどこかに隠れます
もし見つけられなければ
僕の勝ちです
開始してしまいました。
これでもう始まっています
なんか身代わりを好きなとかに置いていらしいです
ここに置かせていただきます僕の身代わり
２０分間ここから始まるんで
隠れましょう　ここしかないっすよねもう　ないっす
まずここで２０分間待ちます。
鳥肌が止まんないすね　　悪寒がすごい
やばいですよね
あと１４分です　長い、、、
換気扇止まってません？
鳴ってますよね
なんで　　当たりました？　　　　絶対当たんないすよ
なんでなんでなんでなんでなんで
ゴンッ⊾☈
どっから鳴りました？
まって　まって
やってる俺よりどうなってるんすか
勝負は勝ったんすけど
儀式ちゃんと終わらせないと良くないんで花子さんの元へ行きましょう
勝ったんで　　　怒ってましたよ
全員回収
大丈夫です大丈夫です　ちゃんといます
全員回収しました
最後にこれはばらばらに破って終わりということでございます
これもやだなぁ
でも
勝負には勝ったので
また次回も危ない儀式を
ようへゐ君の家でやってー　逝くぅ